All sessions have a file system backing them that can
be accessed. If you go to the URL that is
here's a previous run, for example, that we generated a
comic book from. If we open in a new tab
that same URL but we remove the web page part
so that we just access the root directory of that
session, we can access the file system itself for that
session. Now this comes with a number of interesting features
First of all, we can download the entire directory as
a zip file. We can look at any markdown
files, we can look at any HTML files, uh, and
directly view them, of course, and we can also view
uh markdown as HTML files that does a dynamic rendering
You can also view them as text files. If you
this is um in a way that won't trigger a
download for your browser. And you can also view markdown
files as PDFs, and that also does a dynamic rendering
of the markdown file system has built-in git support, so
you can View. If you're not aware, Git is a
version control system for file systems, so that it's basically
like a time machine so that you can track all
of the file changes and if needed, roll back. Um
accessing the root file system for any given session via
this interface gives you a powerful, um, backdoor
into the system functionality. And provides
a good level of hackability and transparency for any. Cognotic
application of the file system is shown here. Uh, so
if you want, you can mount this with a development
environment or you can open it in the file system
explorer or whatever you want to do. I hope that
functionality is useful to you.